we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p we are
trying to keep the voicemails non virus
focused here is a biden voter saying she
liked bernie better but voted biden
because she does not believe bernie can
win take a look
my name is Mary O'Brien I'm living in a
large facility and I'm voting for Biden
I wanted to vote for Bernie but I didn't
think he could win I liked him better
but I want I want Trump defeated thank
you so I am hearing this from a fair
number of people the latest polls
suggest either that Biden and Bernie are
doing equally well against Donald Trump
in hypothetical matchups or that Biden
is doing a little better than Bernie but
I'll tell you with everything going on
with the virus I believe that the
polling is going to be thrown completely
out of whack Joe Biden his press
conferences about the virus have not
been great his interviews about the
virus have not been great Bernie's been
doing live streams and talking about
solutions I have no idea whether this
will reopen the window of opportunity
for Bernie but there is one person
explaining their vote for Biden despite
liking Bernie more tonight chess
tournament 8:00 p.m. Eastern I'll be
streaming it it'll be on Leach s org I
invite you to join me
otherwise I will speak to you on the
bonus show in mere minutes or tomorrow
back on the program